First of all,
social media is free.
So that's the best
thing that somebody
would have going for
them is that their--
their own marketing team.
So if you start small
and you figure out
what it is that you have to
offer and then go from there.
I think it's
really important what
you say about social media being
free, because if you've got--
Oh, yeah.
--if you know your product and
you know yourself and you know
what you can offer to people,
you can put that out there
on social media and grow a
community over time that can
then support whatever it is
you're trying to sell, right?
Well, and you have your
very own focus group.
Uh-huh.
It's like a built-in focus
group of really testing ideas.
You must have-- each one of us
has various things inside of us
that we have as a dream--
Yeah.
--or something we'd
love to do, you know?
We just-- you have to really dig
deep, figure out what that is.
And then if you
have a focus group,
like a social media
platform, then you
can sort of figure out
what's going to work for you.
Yeah.
I remember Kim on
Twitter in the early days
was choosing a color
cap for her fragrance.
Right.
And she was also choosing--
asking people what she should
wear to one of the
awards ceremonies.
It was something that
she taught the rest of us--
how to utilize social
media in figuring out,
you know, how your
community responds to you,
who's following you, and then
how to engage with those people
and have a relationship.
And that was something that
she taught the rest of us.
Is when she did
that first fragrance
and she said, "what color
should I do the bottle?"
Yeah.
I was shocked how
many people responded.
Yeah.
And then she actually did--
The one that--
--follow what
everybody voted for.
Right.
So I thought that
was really also gaining
the trust of the people
that were following her,
because they believed that she
was going to listen to them.
Well, I have a very small,
intimate, powerful, kick ass,
just state of the art team.
I'm so proud of you
guys and everything
that we built together.
And I think that, for me, one
of the things that's been--
you can probably answer this
better than I, because you're--
[LAUGHS] you're the leader
of the team at times.
But I think that, for me,
it's trusting one another.
And we have longevity together.
We've been through
so much together,
which a lot of people
that are starting out
don't have that yet.
Right.
But I think that you have
to, again, use your instincts.
It's about chemistry.
And I think that when
we're on the same page,
and when you're on the
same page as your partners
and your teammates,
that that's everything.
Being available to people,
even though you have, like,
the craziest--
You have to be available.
You have to.
You have to be dialed in.
You have to be connected.
You have to know what's
going on all the time.
And you have to be ready for
whatever is thrown your way.
Yeah.
I mean, every single day we--
I feel like a fireman.
Yeah.
You know?
We're just putting out fires
left and right all the time.
And I think that with
that attitude of anything
is possible, that
goes a long way.
I think everybody has
self-doubt from time to time.
I mean, I do, you know,
often think, "OK, is this--
am I doing," especially
because I'm everyone's manager
and I don't want to
disappoint anybody.
And I'm a people pleaser--
I really am.
As strong as I am, it's--
that soft, you know?
There's another side of me
that just wants everybody
to be happy--
Yeah.
--everybody to be, you
know, in control of their day,
happy about the decisions
that we're making.
You know, so that's
my self-doubt.
It's not actually doubt, it's
just I'm a people pleaser.
I think you have to
have really tough skin.
I mean, any time you enter
the world of social media,
you're opening yourself
up for criticism.
And it's just part of what
these platforms are subject to.
And I think that you
have to stay focused
on what you're doing, stay
focused on what is happening,
and--
and what you really want to
communicate to the people that
are following you, and not worry
about complete strangers that
are criticizing you
and attacking you
that have never even met you.
Right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]